Germany's Parliament has recognized a
famine in Ukraine a famine that happened
90 years ago as genocide perpetrated by
Russia
ukrainians recently commemorated the
fellow demore a famine deliberately
engineered by Soviet leader Joseph
Stalin at least 3.9 million people died
of hunger between 1932 and 1933 while
Moscow targeted Ukraine with
increasingly repressive measures
several countries have already condemned
the holotomur as genocide against the
Ukrainian people including Ireland
Moldova and Romaine
now here is the green party politician
Robin Wagner opening today's debate
this horror was not caused by a force of
nature not by faithful crop failures on
Ukraine's fertile land
this horror was caused by the Kremlin
the dictator made the cruel decision
there to impose collectivization by
force and cause starvation
and the killing by starvation also aimed
at the political suppression of the
Ukrainian national Consciousness
Ukrainian culture and language
my next guest Alexander Sherbert is a
former ambassador to Austria from
Ukraine he's also the author of Ukraine
versus Darkness a collection of essays
based on the two and a half decades he
spent as a career Diplomat and
speechwriter for a Ukrainian leaders
Ambassador it's good to have you back on
the program
I have to ask you your country is in the
midst of a war a fifth of the territory
is occupied right now by Russia another
third is being bombed Into Darkness and
and frigid winter coldness what can the
recognition of the holodimore as
genocide by the German Parliament what
can that do to help ukrainians right now
well one should understand the scope of
this tragedy uh you mentioned three and
a half million people when I was
Ambassador in Austria I was uh
explaining this to austrians imagine
that during one winter the whole Vienna
uh grads Limbs and plug and Fork would
die uh the most horrible slow
humiliating death it's our Ukraine is a
traumatized Nation a nation uh that was
heard deeply by the Kremlin the very
force that we are fighting right now uh
every family has stories about you know
what's what's happened
uh in those in that the terrible winter
or in in the case of my family we have
had a 12 year old girl Marina who
survived like the whole family of the
winter but when the tree blossoming time
came she saw Acacia blossoming and she
started eating think she just ran for it
started eating couldn't stop and if you
eat too much Blossom you die because
it's toxic every family has stories like
that so for us emotionally it's
extremely extremely important also we
hoped will contribute for uh to for
Germany and other countries to
understand better why we don't want uh
to give up to this power called the
Kremlin well yeah there is a connection
isn't there between what happened 90
years ago and what is happening right
now I mean does the the meaning of the
holodomor has it changed or is it
stronger now in the collective memory of
ukrainians because of the current
Russian invasion
well we the realization of the scope of
the score uh it was with us all these
years especially under President
yushenko he dedicated a lot of you know
effort to to uh study what happened uh
what's important for us is uh is the
this political uh Dimension quite
frankly I remember from my uh diplomatic
career how long uh the United States
were absolutely clear about uh Armenian
Genocide but didn't recognize it because
turkey was a strategic partner of the
United States once it never wasn't the
Strategic partner there was a
recognition so on Germany's part it's a
sure side of this you know outside and
when the turn of times that uh finally
this fixation on Russia is not there
anymore
and the message from the outside also
seems to to be a a confirmation of what
you already know to be true and that is
Ukraine is a nation-state because that
fact has been put into question by
Russian President Vladimir Putin with
this Invasion right
absolutely it's just it's historically
uh politically psychological it's huge
it's it's important but first of all
quite frankly I me personally I expect
Germany to understand more clear right
now why we fight well because uh it's
it's the same power that killed three
and a half million people 90 years ago
the Kremlin hasn't changed much since
then
at least at the beginning of this War uh
they published uh the article called
what to do with Ukraine and described
what they want uh to do their plans and
it included everything it included Mass
executions it included it included uh
you know eradication of Ukrainian
culture and language it was a Stalin you
know
era document and it was stunning how
little Russia has changed ever since
well I'm going to sound like like a
cynic here but there are some people who
could say that the German Parliament
voted to recognize the hello more as a
genocide because of of its own guilty
conscience because Germany did not act
quickly enough when the Russian invasion
began back in February
is is that possible or is that just a
cynical view of seeing what happened
today
uh I hope you'll hold also includes the
fact that this three and a half million
uh ukrainians died without Europe
knowing and caring 90 years ago imagine
such a tragedy going on and this you
know information is leaking to uh Europe
well uh Germany had its uh you know uh
special uh time uh during those years so
I don't know whether Germany at all
cared about things that were happening
outside the country but the whole Europe
must have bad conscience about that
because because all these you know
innocent people died 90 years ago
without Europe really caring and you're
certainly
cares now at least that's the message
and that includes Germany what does
Ukraine need and want from Germany right
now
Ukraine needs weapons to prevent a new
genocide and you genocide that would be
inevitable in this scope on smaller
scope but you know any uh compromise
with the genocidal Mania is a compromise
with the genocide so stop pushing us and
stop seeing us as stubborn ukrainians uh
who enjoy this war we don't but we know
too well what awaits us if we lose so
please give us air defense please give
us weapons please give us leopards your
wonderful wonderful uh tanks German
produced it's it would be historically a
good thing
Alexander Sherburne the former Ukrainian
ambassador to Austria Ambassador we
appreciate your time and your valuable
insights tonight thank you
thank you